At long last, the first full trailer for Venom
has arrived.
The film, which focuses on Tom Hardy as journalist
Eddie Brock, is the second big-screen appearance
of every comic fan's favorite alien symbiote.
After the first brief teaser of the film conveyed
more about the tone of Venom than its actual
content, fans finally have their first real
look at what this movie will be about, and,
more importantly, what Venom's iconic costume
is going to look like this time around.
The Venom trailer shows us glimpses of Hardy's
Brock, the villainous Life Foundation, and
plenty more.
Amid the explosions, alien symbiote attacks,
and sinister narration, there are a number
of key plot points and details the trailer
offers that you might've missed the first
time around.
Here are some of the small details you may
have missed in the Venom trailer.
A lethal protector
There aren't a ton of great comics that depict
Venom as a hero.
The most notable recent ones don't even feature
Eddie Brock in the starring role.
As such, there are only so many Venom comics
from which the film could draw inspiration,
and from the trailer, it looks like the film
will be a loose adaptation of Venom: Lethal
Protector.
The '90s miniseries sees Venom and Eddie relocating
to San Francisco as fugitives from Spider-Man
and the authorities.
They do so under an agreement that, as long
as they don't hurt anyone and stay out of
Spidey's business, Spider-Man will stay out
of theirs.
The book features them taking on Carlton Drake
and the LIFE Foundation, both of which appear
in the trailer.
Voice of the people
Fans of the character may find themselves
pleasantly surprised by the direction in which
Venom takes Eddie Brock when it comes to his
career choice.
The prior big screen incarnation of the character
from Spider-Man 3 depicts Eddie Brock as a
photographer, and a pretty skeevy one at that.
From the looks of it, Venom will set Brock
on a different path, one with ties to some
of the character's best comic appearances.
The Eddie Brock we'll get in the film looks
to be an investigative journalist, a career
the character had in the original Spider-Man
comics where he first appeared.
The Venom: Lethal Protector comic series further
establishes Brock as having been inspired
by journalistic coverage of the Watergate
scandal, which gave Brock an underlying anti-authoritarian
streak that could translate to film very well.
It's a smart decision for a version of Venom
that looks to be more anti-hero than supervillain.
As an investigative journalist, Brock should
have a strong sense of right and wrong.
And we get a look at his willingness to make
bad people uncomfortable in the name of the
truth in the Venom trailer.
It's a great character decision and bodes
well for Brock as a likeable protagonist.
A dapper villain
The Venom trailer also gives us our first
real look at the film's villain: Carlton Drake,
played by Riz Ahmed.
Drake is another carryover from Lethal Protector,
albeit one with which the filmmakers seem
to have taken a few liberties.
In the comics, Drake is an older man running
the Life Foundation.
He's a shady dude, but he's not responsible
for Venom and Eddie's bonding, nor for the
discovery of the original symbiote, although
he does discover the existence of others.
It looks like Ahmed's take on the character
will be significantly different.
Ahmed is young and attractive, and, by the
looks of it, he'll be a prominent media figure
in the world of the film.
He's also far more directly tied to the symbiotes'
presence on Earth, with his Life Foundation
seeming to be responsible for either discovering
the symbiotes or bringing them to Earth to
begin with.
It makes for a villain far more directly tied
to the protagonist, and that's likely going
to be a good thing.
Love is in the air
We get our first look at the dynamic between
Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock and Michelle Williams'
Anne Weying in the Venom trailer as well.
In the comics, Weying is Brock's ex-wife,
even though they appear to be together in
this cinematic take.
Their relationship may still be a bit complicated,
since in the comics she also eventually gets
a symbiote of her own and becomes the villainous
She-Venom.
With multiple symbiotes at play in the film,
let's not rule out an appearance from that
particular alter-ego just yet.
A complicated relationship
The relationship between a host and a symbiote
in Marvel comics isn't necessarily defined
by a strict set of rules, but generally speaking,
there's usually a decision made on the part
of the host to bond with it.
"Why would we do that?"
Here, it's not clear how much of a choice
Eddie Brock has about sharing his body.
Eddie doesn't even seem to understand what's
happening to him during the bonding process.
And when his Venom powers are finally unleashed
on the men who come to his apartment looking
for their boss's "property," he seems just
as shocked by what happens as they are.
It's a pretty cool storytelling choice, one
that opens up possible explorations of body
horror and Eddie's loss of autonomy as the
host, cemented by the symbiote's chilling
line:
"We can do whatever we want.
Do we have a deal?"
So, Venom will not only have a mind of his
own in the film, but also a voice.
We hear him speaking to Eddie in the trailer.
Since there are obviously two distinct and
separate characters that happen to occupy
the same body, we're all in for the inevitable
struggle for control and dominance between
the two.
One giant leap for mankind
The Venom symbiote origin story of the comics
is a little bit complicated, but basically
Spider-Man finds the Venom symbiote while
he's in another dimension, fighting in the
Beyonder's Secret Wars with the rest of the
Marvel Universe.
And since Peter Parker's being shared between
Marvel and Sony, it looks like Venom is going
to cook up its own, streamlined origin story
instead.
The Venom trailer seems to reveal that, rather
than Eddie discovering Venom through Spider-Man,
the Life Foundation does.
It also skips the element of Venom's origin
where it masquerades as a superhero suit.
The alien that the foundation discovers is
in pure symbiote form.
There appears to be no intended trickery on
its part.
The audience, and the film's characters, will
see it in its true, goopy form from the start.
And a goopy Venom is a happy Venom!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!